brothers and sisters just imagine for a
second that you give £10 in donation and
that £10 is used to buy food or bricks
or whatever to help the people in Gaza
but then just imagine this amazing V
that you want to do but we turn it into
a money-making machine how the W is
exactly that they take your money and
the money that we are going to put in in
this W this building and every single
time the money generated from that W
that building is going to go to our
Palestinian brothers and sister for the
next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years and
this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subh bless and preserve you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends today I came to stford to do
some da with the brothers here but I
came across a video of khabib actually
speaking to Donald Trump first I thought
is maybe AI generated but it's actually
a real video of him talking to him and
if I'm not mistaken he's basically
telling him to stop the war on Palestine
obviously some people criticize him or
saying not criticize him but saying you
know what what change is he going to do
like who cares he's he's built the uh
the embassy put the embassy in Jerusalem
Etc here's the video in actually khabib
and Donald Trump are never before the
the these individual meet here's the
video I got to see I think this could be
well 50 times thank you man you know I I
don't know I got a little girl love
I got to see I think this could
be so guys what you saw there for
yourselves final brother sisters now
it's very profound because some people
said what's the point do you think he's
going to listen do you think he cares
it's not going to change no problem but
he is following a clear Hadi from the
prophet which is what if you see evil
try to change it with your hand
physically try to stop it and say this
is maybe for a ruler if he has the
authority to stop it if not speak out
against it this is what Habib is doing
by at least you might say what's he
going to do ET you don't know at least
he is speaking out against the evil and
asking him to stop if irrelevant we do
not look for results we look for the
effort that we do Allah is going to ask
us did you speak out against it so
alhamdulillah Al saw the opportunity and
look at that he could have be thinking
about Al he could have ignored Trump he
could have been hostile towards him he
could have whatever he went to him and
said what try to stop the war in
Palestine at least he spoke out against
it how many people are out there who
haven't even made a tweet who haven't
even spoken about who done nothing about
it they are complicit in the evil like
Allah says in the Quran when he told B
is not to fish in the Sabbath and they
did Allah destroyed two of them who the
first one was the ones who were doing
the act of trying to trick Allah by
putting Nets to fish in the Sabbath
number two were those who were warning
them don't do it they were enjoining the
good and forbid in evil number three
were those who were silent Allah schol
say Allah destroyed the ones who broke
the Sabbath and the ones who did not
speak out against it so khib spoke out
against it and the lowest of IM man is
what hate it in your heart so that's
exactly what done and may Allah bless
and preserve him in and you guys should
do the same speak out against in brother
sisters